in this lesson you're gonna learn how to
find the landal area surface area in
volume of a cone and the first we want
to talk about is how to work with the
formulas so if you're already familiar
with pyramids the formulas are very
similar for a cone the lateral area is
1/2 the perimeter of the base times the
slant height the perimeter of the base
you can see that's actually going to be
a circle so that's the circumference of
a circle so we can replace the perimeter
with 2 PI R and then L is like the
leaning height the slant height here and
so you can see 1/2 times 2 is 1 so that
just comes out 2 pi RL for the lateral
area or the sides ok have the call if
you want to find the surface area you
just take that lateral area which we
just found PI RL and you add on the area
of the base of course the base in a cone
is a circle so we use the formula for
area of a circle PI R squared and then
for volume you can find the area of the
base times the height divided by 3 and
the way to think about this is see you
had like a cylinder what's the formula
for volume of the cylinder well it's the
area of the base times the height but
imagine if you put a cone inside of that
cylinder with the same base and the same
height you could actually fit three of
these cones inside of this cylinder this
1 plus 2 more so really this one cone on
its own is only get taking up 1/3 of the
volume of the cylinder so the area of
the base course is a circle so that's
going to be area of a circle PI R
squared and then the height we want is
actually that perpendicular height right
here not the slant height but the
shortest distance between the two bases
here so that simplifies down at just 1/3
PI R squared each so let's go ahead and
apply these formulas to number one here
how do we find the lateral area well
we're just going to use the pi RL
formula so pi we know is 3.14 or you
could just leave it as pi the radius is
7 and the L is like you're leanin height
that's your slant height well in this
particular problem they didn't give us
the slant height but because we have a
right triangle we can do the Pythagorean
theorem to find the slant height or if
you recognize that this is
Pythagorean triple it's a seven 2425
Fagor e and triple that's our slant
height so seven times 25 is a hundred
and seventy five PI units squared so
it's unit squared for area if we want to
find the surface area we just have to
take the lateral area which is the sides
of the cone plus the base which is PI R
squared so we're just gonna add on pi
times the radius which is seven squared
that's 49 pi plus 175 so what does that
come out to we've got four looks like
224 pi units squared and then if we want
to find the volume we just have to do
the area of the base times the height
divided by three or times one-third or
you can use the 1/3 pi radius squared
times the height and you want that
perpendicular height not the slant
height the slant height is you use when
you're finding that lateral area and not
the not the volume so let's see here we
have 1/3 7 squared is 49 times 24 well
one-third times 24 that's going to
reduced it 8 + 49 times 8
let's see what that comes out to okay
its 392 PI units cubes remember for
volume you want cubic units and you've
got it if you want to see more examples
involving like cylinders and prisms and
pyramids and spheres I put those all
together in one video right there where
you can see how the different formulas
interrelate with one another and you can
get some more practice with these
problems I'll see you over in that video
right there